من شرق الخرطوم وراسل الجزيره اسامه سيد
احمد اسامه نود الاطلاع على اخر التطورات
الميدانيه بعد انتهاء الهدن وعدم تمديدها
عثمان لما ينتظر الطرفان الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع انتظار انتهاء الهدنه
الممدده
هدنه الخمسه ايام التي انتهت في مساء امس
عند التاسعه وخمس واربعين دقيقه ولكن يعني
تشتعل الجبهات القتال بين الجانبين قبل
الهدنه وبعد انتهاء هذه الهدنه صباح اليوم
سمعنا دوي انفجارات عنيفه ناجمه عن يعني
اطلاق قذائف من الاسلحه الثقيله في عده
مواقع من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم في
منطقه جنوب الخرطوم وفي منطقه جنوب شرق
الخرطوم كذلك شهدت قصفا المدفعيا عنيفا
يعني سمع دويه في مسافات بعيده من هذا
المكان ايضا في مدينه ام درمان جنوب مدينه
ام درمان ايضا شهدت قصفا عنيفا متتاليا
اللي مدفعيه ثقيله في منطقه الخرطوم بحري
صباح اليوم ايضا شهدت يعني
سمع دوي انفجارات عنيفه ايضا وكان هناك
تحليق وقصف بالطائرات الحربي لاهداف يعتقد
انها لمناطق التمركز لقوات الدعم السريع
وسمعت ايضا يعني اصوات المضادات الارضيه
التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع اذن الجبهات
القتال لا تزال مشتعله وما بعد هذه الهدنه
التي انتهت عند التاسعه وخمس واربعين
دقيقه
وكذلك لم تكن هذه التطورات فقط هنا في
الخرطوم كذلك في ولايه غربي الدارفور في
مدينه الجنينه وبحسب مصادر طبيه اكدت لنا
ان الالاف من المواطنين
الذين يوجدون في مدينه الجنينه يهربون
بشكل يومي من القتال لعده ايام في مدينه
الجنينه
وهؤلاء الذين يهربون من جبهات القتال خوفا
من
خوفا من الرصاص والموت يواجهون كذلك
صعوبات انسانيه وامنيه كبيره خاصه وانهم
يعني بحسب المصادر انهم يواجهون القتل
والسلب والنهب في طريق هروبهم الى الى
دوله تشاد كذلك في في الجنوب الخرطوم كانت
هناك سلسله انفجارات قويه هزه ارجاء هذه
المناطق ونجمت عن عن مقتل خمسه اشخاص وجرح
26 شخصا اخرين نتيجه لسقوط قذائف
لاسلحه ثقيله في عدد في عده في عده
احياء في جنوب الخرطوم خاصه حيي الازهري
ومايوه